hello everybody welcome back to let's
play cry of fear and we're still being
chased by those guys I had to hurry
because it's running out of time
breathing down my neck okay there was a
shovel back there oh hello crazy
coming up punk
dead dead oh that's the big guy
well that guy's not really moving with a
purpose I just aimlessly wandering you
to get stuck on each other oh oh so many
what the hell what the hell hey guys you
stay in your little pen there I'll go do
some other stuff that's interesting
have fun your little powwow over there
make my way to the land of progress
um there's a shovel here so obviously
it's another digging part of Oh God
Oh can I drop I don't want to lose
anything crap oh I'm almost out of
shotgun ammo I'll drop that for now
no not hang on I'll be right with you
ah okay where the heck can I dig ah
right here use it hi hey hey okay go
around you get that maybe I can kill
these guys I have no idea I don't see
what I'm supposed to do just yet
I don't think there's probably no point
in killing those guys anyway so I won't
bother but I guess I just dig around
until I find something no no even if I
find something I don't have the
inventory space to carry it mean
inventory space here is this so
unbelievably tiny okay that's the only
hole here nope there's another one right
here all right it's all right cool okay
useful bullets but all in all I need
something more story progressing bye bye
bye bye guys
so big flowing dumb there's got to be
more around here nothing and here no
don't see anything nothing nothing
nothing nothing nothing so far
yeah nothing a whole lot of nut come on
what was the point of getting that
shovel then kidding me alright at least
my I shot gonna stop here and I need to
punch these ah with my fist did you see
a walk ha ha ha BAM [ __ ] get out of
hell boom oh yeah okay that's where I'm
supposed to go I shot those with the gun
and when I shot wood before it broke
instantly I don't know what was causing
that to take so much time what what I'm
back here
why oh maybe because I'm more near wait
what I'm so confused now how did I need
to come back here so if his body is
still here
what I'm I'm honestly I'm really
confused I have no idea what I'm doing
where am I supposed to go I don't even
have an objective
okay I got a key for oh no not this not
the BA oh come on really
ah you see this alright I'll be back in
a bit if I reload hello everybody I'm
back okay
um I don't know why that keeps crashing
on me it's kind of kind of breaks the
flow of my Chi anyway um I honestly
don't know where I'm going
Ronald Street key is that the key that I
need that if I go all the way back like
a long way back that's where I needed
yeah okay so they're putting new
monsters in front of me head Splosion
what you can go where'd you go oh don't
tell me you threw your gun down there
you ass bag
okay the plain you monster the front so
headshot so I'm guessing that I'm
supposed to go back this way if they're
putting monsters in front of me okay
yeah yeah definitely okay edge shot all
right so if I just go back this way I
got the key so Ronald Street I don't
know I'm still confused but I'm hoping
that it's just gonna point me in the
right direction boink boink no more
crashing no my weird white screen of
death okay nice peaceful Park all the
aminals go on my merry way no one
bothers me I don't bother that loss it's
all good in this neighborhood yeah I
actually need more FEMA so let me get
that real quick oh what's this
oops super juice yeah
um way back this way that way yeah I'm
glad I don't have to go through those
subway tunnels again that was right
terrifying okay yeah this is Lal looking
familiar I think
they stopped putting enemies in front of
me so I'm assuming I'm going the right
way
hello no I know I know no ha no ha no
one may be out maybe I'm maybe the key
was supposed to be used earlier than
that I kind of feel like I'm just
backpacking in nowhere right now and
that's probably not a good thing but I
got mine now my back in the apartments I
can't be it can't be that far back
already
oh it's the different apartments Oh
baton yes nice stick as they call them
finally I got that back ok there there's
some melee action that way I don't have
to use bullets all the time but I still
feel like I'm not making any progress
now ok well now I'm definitely confused
that was nothing where am I going what
am i doing no no one I'm so going the
wrong way guys
I'm sorry about this I'm probably
wasting you guys it's time right now
because what the heck what the hell
ok seriously what the heck e heck man
yeah there's no enemies here I don't
need this right now damn it damn it I
did I wasted so much time just going
back here I'm an idiot ok I should have
realized it they must have wanted me to
go through the factory or something
again because that's why they would have
put enemies there
and I guess it would been through and
that's why there was no enemy in the
park I should have realized at the park
that I was going the wrong way sorry
about this guys I'll get back as quick
as I can
whoo awesome boot town I got playing to
go around bunk bunk all right let's get
me here long arduous process of getting
back to where I was
oh my pauses folks I will entertain you
with this story or something in bed I'm
gonna brag about guess where I'm going
in July I'm going to Comic Con that's
right my brother
ah my brother is um was invited there
he's got a popular web comic and um some
of you know this because obviously he
referred me and he's going to Comic Con
and I'm going with them so that'll be
fun I've never been to Comic Con before
or any convention for that matter so
that will be nice and I'm going slow
again that's the lovely that's so lovely
yeah I'm excited I'm gonna meet like
we'll Shatner Picasso Amy Poehler I
don't know who goes there but I'll meet
them all all the celebrities I'm
actually gonna bring my camera so when
the time comes I'll post pictures on my
facebook page I'll be real so jealous
right now
gonna be Amy Poehler I don't know she
probably don't go to Comicon
alright let's try this way this way
gonna throw enemies at me maybe maybe no
I don't know why Holland or open hole
you know aha wow wow what's wrong with
you what did he have a book on his head
a box what was wrong with his head look
a hell was that
where's my assault rifle screw that
he's a shotgun I got enough bullets for
the shotgun come on damn reload lock and
load buddy
Jebus how many different types of
monsters aren't there in this game not
that I'm complaining I love it but man
if he is all hell okay so I'm going the
right way I think hope so
ah do not like oh I see you yep
that hurt didn't it oh is that cool gone
oh just like that
nope drop off what's that nope robbed
all right Harbor Avenue second Avenue
Harbor Road how bit about Harbor Road
that sounds familiar
[Music]
maybe maybe it's familiar maybe oh no
this is where I was this is where my
voice got pretty feminine where's the
jam can't open it
I'm so confused I don't even have in my
notes I don't have an objective why
don't I have an objective anywhere that
I can pull up and review hmm up to now
I've only had like Oh training ups in
until now I've only had minor pet peeves
about this game but that's a big one
getting lost is one of my least favorite
things yeah about a game that's why
valve games are good subconsciously you
don't realize it but you never get lost
in a valve game or a half-life or any of
its single-player games at portal
because they play testing so well okay
I've gone this way before
again I'm okay if I don't see a monster
here I'm just going back no monster no
I'm going the wrong way
ah keep going the wrong way bond there -
ball is better - no monster equals wrong
way
that's just my rule from now on I'm
gonna follow that rule I don't see
monsters go the wrong way
okay I feel like I've been trying to get
to Saxon Avenue for years now go riding
on me
okay good this way that way go around in
a circle and jump up and down a few
times and then dance like a monkey and
now it's snow it was just raining how's
it go from rain to snow doesn't even
sleet in between that any more monsters
aha another monster okay making progress
hi
you hit me took like five shots what was
up with that okay so I go back down in
the subway Saxon Avenue up nope
at ketchup all right look a few maybe I
wasn't supposed to go in a big circle
but why would they put enemies in front
of me if I wasn't that Dora is broken
ah okay once again I've seen an enemy
oh don't tell me I'm wrong again holds
that Oh a bed guy is that new or did I
run past you before I ran past jump on
you egg dad all right
oh come on you wimp
I gotta cut it here sorry about the lack
of progress I've just been running in
circles that's just sad
yeah I'm going the wrong way again that
must have just been a recycle enemy but
anyway thanks guys so much for watching
I really do appreciate it and as always
I will see you in the next part
bye bye